[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kreisel
berichte und christian sievers
guten abend hinein
es wird ernst bei unseren nachbarn in
österreich gilt ab heute nacht der
lockdown für ungeimpfte alle über zwölf
ohne impfung dürfen wir zu hause dann
nur noch aus dringenden gründen
verlassen das wirkt wie impfpflicht
durch die hintertür manche sehen es als
impfpflicht durch die vordertür es ist
auf jeden fall eine dringende mahnung
der regierung und gleichzeitig eine
sofortmaßnahme weil die infektionen
rasant zunehmen deutschland hat
österreich wieder zum hochrisiko gebiet
erklärt aber auch bei uns greift das
virus um sich auch bei uns heute neue
rekord incident und
gleichzeitig tobt der streit darüber was
denn jetzt zu tun ist zwischen teilen
der noch regierung und der möglichen
neuen deutschland nimmt sich viel zeit
für die diskussion zeit die dieses land
kaum noch hat nicole diekmann berichtet
aus berlin aber vorher noch die
situation in österreich von zdf wien
korrespondentin britta hilpert
die schneedecke der tiroler berge ist
zurzeit in etwa so dünn wie das
nervenkostüm der hoteliers unten im tal
im sporthotel eagles läuft die
wintersaison an da treffen gleich zwei
schlechte nachrichten für deutsche gilt
österreich als hochrisiko gebiet und ab
montag gibt es einen lock down für
ungeimpfte
schlecht für das geschäft die rekord ins
identen von über 800 ja grundsätzlich
sind diese zahlen die wir in österreich
haben alles andere wie erfreulich wir
wissen auch dass die institute und dann
nämlich geimpften sei sehr hoch ist das
heißt es muss müssen alles bewegen damit
ihr die gäste aber auch natürlich unsere
einheimischen impfung bekommen kostenlos
und ohne termin so leicht mal dass
einheimische noch macht nur 65 prozent
kamen zur impfung und das obwohl die
regierung vielfach auf die spritze
drängt nur genesene oder geimpfte dürfen
in österreich zum beispiel haare
schneiden schnitzel essen gehen und
nachtclubs besuchen trotzdem seien die
intensivstationen beide am limit heißt
es vor allem wegen umgekippter deshalb
gilt ab montag der selektive lockdown
ungeimpfte dürfen dann nur noch raus mit
guten gründen wir setzen diesen schritt
nicht leichten herzens aber leider ist
er notwendig gleich aber auch das ist
die unterkante der maßnahmen denn es
kann sein dass das nicht reicht in
salzburg und oberösterreich verbieten
sie auch auf weihnachtsmärkten die nacht
gastronomie wird geschlossen
veranstaltung abgesagt maßnahmen die
auch geimpfte treffen denn hier herrscht
eine inzidenz von über 1000 experten
meinen ein locker und für ungeimpfte
greife zu kurz da zusatznutzen den man
erzielt wird wahrscheinlich nicht
ausreichen um in oberösterreich oder
salzburg die zahlen so drastisch nach
unten zu bringen wie es eigentlich
notwendig wäre die einen protestieren
gegen den lockt die anderen stehen an am
impfzentrum meist für ihren dritten
stich und viele in dieser schlange
fragen sich ob es bei den lockt nur für
ungeimpfte bleiben kann in deutschland
wie hier im nordrhein westfälischen
ibbenbüren weiten sie testzentren aus zu
impfzentren die zahlen explodieren
weiter der siebte tag in folge mit der
höchsten je gemessenen inzidenz
mancherorts bringt das die leute dazu
sich nun doch impfen zu lassen das
allein aber ist keine effektive waffe im
kampf gegen die vierte welle weiß auch
die ampel die shaft ihre pläne nun nach
der bundesarbeitsminister legt einen
gesetzentwurf vor dazu gehört dass wir
konsequent 3 gegen den betrieben
durchsetzen das heißt dass der zutritt
zu unternehmen nur für geimpfte genesene
oder getestete gilt und das gehört auch
dazu dass für home office wieder dort in
kraft setzen wo immer es möglich ist der
alarm der fachleute wird immer
dringlicher denn die lage auf den
intensivstationen spitzt sich zu die
ampel partei näher und sich derweil
weiter an 3g in zügen die pläne von
hubertus heil darauf kann man sich
einigen und die grünen könnten sich nun
durchsetzen mit einer ihrer
kernforderungen das bedeutet aber auch
dass man jetzt prüfen muss für bestimmte
berufsgruppen gerade im
gesundheitsbereich gerade im
pflegebereich auch über verpflichtende
impfung nachzudenken
markus söder aber geht all das nicht
weit genug 2g und masken pflicht in der
gastronomie und bei veranstaltungen
zweig plus in clubs bayern verschärft ab
dienstag die regeln und nennt die von
der ampel geplanten wörtlich in jeder
hinsicht unzureichend wir stolpern quasi
mit kurzen hosen und sommerreifen in
einen eiskalten winter es wird nicht
funktionieren
in elf tagen am 25 läuft die epidemische
lage von nationaler tragweite aus erst
am donnerstag aber treffen sich bund und
länder zur ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
das kleinste bundesland ist
unangefochten impf meister in
deutschland der bremer bürgermeister
andreas bovenschulte spd ist vor der
abend bei uns genannte bürgermeister
sicher in großer not darf man ratschläge
geben was hat die bremerinnen und bremer
mehr überzeugt vom impfen als die
menschen sonst wo in deutschland ich
glaube die bremerinnen und bremer sind
insgesamt sehr aufgeschlossen gegenüber
dem britischen bremen ist eine liberale
weltoffene hansestadt und da steht man
neuen dingen und eben auch dem impfen
grundsätzlich aufgeschlossen gegenüber
aber wir haben denke ich eine sehr
ordentliche zentrale impfkampagne
organisiert die hat die leute auch
organisiert und drittens haben wir
natürlich eins gemacht wir sind sofort
in die quartiere gegangen auch in die
mit hohen instanzen und mit niedrigen
impfquoten und sind direkt an die leute
ran gegangen und das hat uns viel
zuspruch gebracht aber die pandemie ist
nicht vorbei auch in bremen nicht dabei
hatten sie mal gesagt bei 80 prozent
geimpften und die haben sie bei sich in
bremen dann können wir in den
normalzustand zurück da haben auch sie
sich gerührt oder ja das ist ich habe
damals gesagt wenn wir 80 prozent folge
kämpfte erreichen dann müssen wir
darüber nachdenken ob wir in den
normalzustand zurückkehren können ich
habe gesagt das kann dann nicht der fall
sein wenn die infektions lage zu
schlecht ist und so sieht's jetzt leider
aus ich habe das nicht so erwartet dass
wir auch bei einer so hohen impfquote
tatsächlich auch die gefahr steigender
zahlen in diesem maße haben wie wir das
jetzt sehen viele forscher sagen sie
haben wartet die politiker eher nicht
was passiert denn jetzt was soll denn
jetzt passieren wir haben jetzt erst mal
wie wir gerade gehört haben am
donnerstag der kommenden woche eine
weitere eine neue
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz haben wir
noch so viel zeit also wir brauchen
jetzt zwei dinge wir brauchen ganz klare
bundeseinheitliche maßnahmen der
pandemie bekämpfung das haben wir eben
gehört das bedeutet es pflicht in den
betrieben home office pflicht
impfpflicht für bestimmte berufsgruppen
aber auch einheitlich regeln für die
anwendung von 2g aber wir brauchen
ergänzend auch eine hotspot strategie
für besonders betroffene regionen die
geltende rechtslage gibt das alles her
und wir müssen sicherstellen dass das
auch künftig möglich bleibt damit in dem
besonders betroffenen gebieten auch
besondere maßnahmen ergriffen werden
können weil man kann landkreis mit einer
hunderte incidents nicht genauso
behandeln wie ein landkreis mit einer
tausender residenz berufen schuld was
sie da gerade alles aufgezählt haben
wird das kommen jetzt am donnerstag wird
das beschlusslage der länder sein was
hören sie denn von den kolleginnen und
kollegen also ich gehe davon aus dass
der zunächst vorgelegte gesetzentwurf
oder die formulierungshilfe nochmal
deutlich nachgeschärft wird insbesondere
soll es wohl auch eine
länderöffnungsklausel
geben damit diejenigen länder die
besonders hohe instanzen haben also
bayern sachsen oder thüringen dann
tatsächlich auch die notwendigen
maßnahmen ergreifen können da gibt es ja
das problem der niedrigen impfquoten
deshalb sind diese länder besonders
betroffen und wir müssen natürlich die
möglichkeit haben auch scharfe maßnahmen
zu setzen das heißt diese grundidee die
die ampel mal hatte so der ja auch ihre
partei gehören soll die spd die halten
auch sie jetzt für absolut verfehlte es
möglicherweise katastrophales timing
zumindest das ist kein katastrophales
timing wir haben bis zum 25 november die
jetzige rechtslage wie erlaubt alle
maßnahmen auch alle scharfen maßnahmen
die hätten ja klar danach werde eine
andere rechtslage einführen die den
ländern weniger möglichkeiten
gibt die jetzige rechtslage hätte es zum
beispiel haben ermöglicht in bayern alle
maßnahmen schon längst zu ergreifen zum
beispiel auch zweig schon vor zwei
wochen einzuführen dass das nicht
passiert es hat ja nichts mit der
kommenden ampel zu tun sondern dass in
bayern die koalition sich nicht darauf
verständigen konnte und was wir jetzt
nachdem fünfundzwanzigster haben werden
ist eine neue rechtslage die sieht als
grundlage bundeseinheitliche regelung
vor und die wird auch eine
länderöffnungsklausel für besonders
betroffene gebiet enthalten ich finde
das ist ein vernünftiger ansatz mit der
neuen rechtslage zumindest wie sie im
moment auf dem papier steht sagte
bayerns ministerpräsident sondern am
ende steht unser land de facto wertlos
da gegen korona also wehrlos stehen vor
allen dingen die regierungen da die eine
niedrige impfquote haben und die müssen
sich fragen wie können wir unsere
hausaufgaben machen damit wir eine
höhere impfquote bekommen und zweitens
um das noch einmal deutlich zu machen
viele maßnahmen hätten auch schon jetzt
ergriffen werden können ich wundere mich
dass es zweig in bayern erst am nächsten
dienstag in der gastronomie geben wird
das hätte man dann ja auch schon vor
zwei wochen machen können also ich
glaube das führt uns nicht weiter wenn
man mit den fingern aufeinander zeigt
jetzt müssen sich bund und länder
unterhalten und gemeinsam gucken wie wir
diese schwere herausforderung gemeinsam
gut bewältigen irgendwann nochmal dazu
brauchen wir zwei sachen
bundeseinheitliche regelung und eine
hotspot strategie können sie wir haben
gerade im film gesehen heute der tag in
österreich einen lock down für
ungeimpfte wir haben heute nacht in
österreich gilt für deutschland
ausschließen also ich habe noch nie was
davon gehalten von der ausgangs
beschränkung der flächendeckenden als
mittel der pandemie bekämpfung und ich
glaube das ist der falsche weg ist die
menschen in ihren wohnungen einzusperren
und dann auch noch selektiv zu sagen das
machen wir nur für ungeimpfte wenn man
in einer situation sagt wir sind so
verzweifelt dass wir keinen anderen weg
gehen sehen dann müsste man tatsächlich
sich ehrlich machen und sagen wir wollen
eine allgemeine impfpflicht einführen
aber nicht eine flächendeckende
ausgangssperre für ungeimpfte ich halte
das nicht für einen zielführenden ansatz
sondern für einen ansatz der uns
gesellschaftlich schnell zerreißen kann
eine sache noch schneller bürgermeister
sehr mit mehrfach gesagt wie wichtig
impfen es jetzt ist es so dass die impf
teams in sachsen überlastet sind aktuell
zumindest an vielen orten in bayern gibt
es lange warteschlangen wie kann das
sein dass die politik zum impfen auf
ruft beinahe flehentlich appellierte und
dann geht das tatsächlich doch nur mit
einigen mühen ja das muss man sich
natürlich immer vor ort angucken da kann
ich natürlich nichts zur situation in
bayern und in sachsen sagen wir haben in
bremen immer gute erfahrungen damit
gemacht eine parallele vorgehensweise zu
haben niedergelassene ärzte einerseits
und starke impfzentren andererseits ich
denke das ist der vernünftige weg aber
ich gehe fest davon aus dass die
kolleginnen und kollegen und bayern und
sachsen da auch alles geben um in dieser
situation möglichst viele menschen zu
impfen sagte der bremer bürgermeister
andreas bovenschulte ich danke ihnen
ganz herzlich für das gespräch heute
abend im heute schon mal und nahmen
guten amt
und dann unser nächstes thema heute
abend wie viel leid fehl und
falschinformationen gerade in sozialen
netzwerken anrichten hat mittlerweile
wohl selbst mark zuckerberg gemerkt das
heißt aber nicht dass sie weniger würden
im gegenteil wer aus dem nahen osten ins
flugzeug ausgerechnet nach minsk in
belarus steigt um von dort den
lebensgefährlichen marsch in ein
besseres leben richtung eu zu wagen ist
meist einer ganzen kombination von lügen
geld schinderei und zynische kalkül
aufgesessen der belarussische diktator
scheint aus politischen gründen alles zu
tun um diese route geradezu anzupreisen
schlepperbanden und menschenhändler tun
dann ihr übriges
und dazu kommt die verzweiflung der an
der ostgrenze europas festsitzenden
menschen die sie alles glauben lässt
aktuell das falsche gerücht deutschland
würde busse schicken um sie abzuholen
annafest ist vor ort
es ist freitagnacht in den polnischen
wäldern der bella russischen grenze
aktivisten finden eine achtköpfige
familie die erleichterung spürbar
ich bin bei euch
[Musik]
es ist eine großfamilie zwei kleinen
kinder eltern und großeltern sie kommen
aus dem nordirak einer der männer habe
dort gegen den esg kämpft und fürchten
nun um sein leben mitte oktober sollen
sie ihre heimat verlassen haben und
seien so erzählen sie über die türkei
nach weißrussland gereist wie oft habt
ihr es über die grenze von belarus nach
polen probiert sie die 17 x 17 mal seit
zehn tagen haben die kinder keine milch
mehr bekommen oder ein warmes getränk
die temperaturen sind am gefrierpunkt
trotzdem wollen sie weiter sie hoffen
dieses mal nicht von der polizei
abgeschoben zu werden es wäre das
achtzehnte mal in zwei wochen
17.000 versuche die grenze zu überqueren
wurden alleine im oktober von polnischen
behörden registriert und täglich kommen
neue dazu diese bilder sollen zeigen die
polnische grenze mit laser attacken
angegriffen werden während bella
russische soldaten die grenzanlage
beschädigen
unterwegs am rande der sperrzone entlang
der grenze seit september herrscht im
grenzgebiet ausnahmezustand kein
durchkommen für hilfsorganisationen und
berichterstattern
kamera aus wenige kilometer südlich wird
der lkw stau an dem einzigen offenen
übergang länger wartezeit 50 stunden
schuld seien die migranten und
deutschland findet dieser weißrusse
im radio hört man dass angela merkel die
eingeladen hat
ein wirrwarr aus falsch und
fehlermeldungen in einer mitteilung des
polnischen innenministerium heißt es
unter den migranten verbreitete sich das
gerücht dass am montag busse aus
deutschland kommen alle mitnehmen eine
lüge die polnische seite waren weiter
auch ein ansturm auf die grenze könnte
bevorstehen und zu gefährlichen
situationen führen bei den anwohnern
wächst die angst am tag geht es aber in
der nacht wenn die hunde bellen das
fühlt sich nicht gut an die grenzzäune
kann man leicht einreißen mit einem
spaten es wäre sicherer wenn sie eine
mauer bauen eine hohe mauer ganz hoch
unangenehm sie sehen doch die
hubschrauber
am abend erhalten wir eine nachricht von
der familie aus dem nordirak sie wurden
doch erwischt von der polizei auch ihr
achtzehnter versuch ist gescheitert nun
sind sie zurück im weißrussischen wald
in der kälte aufgeben wollen sie
trotzdem nicht
und jetzt noch ein thema das die welt in
atem hält weit über diesen tag hinaus
kassel ja du meinst die
weltklimakonferenz deren ergebnisse
unterschiedliche reaktionen ausgelöst
haben so sagte un-generalsekretär gute
risch es sei nun zeit in den notfall
modus zu gehen und die deutsche
aktivistin luisa neubauer nannte die
abschluss erklärung einen betrug an
allen jungen menschen die rund 200
teilnehmer staaten hatten sich zum 1,5
grad ziel bekannt und zu einem
beschleunigten kampf gegen die
erderwärmung
allerdings schwächten sie in letzter
minute eine formulierung zum
kohleausstieg ab
bundesumweltministerin schulze zeigte
sich weitgehend zufrieden ich hätte mir
eine stärkere sprache gewünscht ich
hätte mir gewünscht dass man das noch
etwas deutlicher formuliert aber das
historische ist das das erste mal in
einem dokument einer weltklimakonferenz
so etwas konkretes verankert ist das
ende des fossilen zeitalters
bei der präsidentschaftswahl in
bulgarien liegt nach ersten zahlen
amtsinhaber rhade vorn außerdem stimmten
die wähler über ein neues parlament ab
und das zum dritten mal in diesem jahr
denn die wahlen im april und juli hatten
keine mehrheitsfähige regierung hervor
gebracht
prognosen sehen ein enges rennen
zwischen einer neu gegründeten anti
korruptions partei und der partei des
früheren ministerpräsidenten brüssel er
gilt nach korruptionsvorwürfen als
politisch isoliert
vor den kanarischen inseln sind acht
migranten ums leben gekommen ihr boot
hatte mindestens eine woche lang mit
einem motorschaden im atlantik getrieben
insgesamt waren 62 menschen an bord
einige in lebensbedrohlichem zustand
im mittelmeer haben italienische
behörden mehr als 500 migranten gerettet
von zwei verschiedenen schiffen die in
seenot geraten waren im kalabrischen
rutsche jonica wurden sie an land
gebracht
heute ist volkstrauertag das heißt
deutschland gedenkt der opfer von krieg
und gewaltherrschaft an der zentralen
gedenkstätte der neuen wache in berlin
legte bundespräsident steinmeier kränze
nieder begleitet von vertretern aller
verfassungsorgane bei einer gedenkfeier
im bundestag sagte steinmeier aus dem
gemeinsamen gedächtnis der deutschen
seien viele opfer und orte deutscher
verbrechen verdrängt unter anderem in
ost und südosteuropa
die meisten die als korrespondentin als
reporter aus krisen- und kriegsgebieten
berichten stehen irgendwann vor einem
ganz persönlichen dilemma sind sehr nah
dran an sehr viel elend sie sehen leid
und erleben schicksale und können selbst
doch direkt kaum helfen und eben nur
berichten manchmal kann man das nur
weglassen wir wissen wie unfassbar groß
die hilfsbereitschaft der menschen in
deutschland ist die hilfsbereitschaft
unserer zuschauerinnen und zuschauer von
ihnen und wir sind doch immer wieder neu
überrascht erfreut und ja berührt
diesen beitrag unserer afghanistan
korrespondenten haben wir ihnen vor zwei
monaten gezeigt katrin eigendorf
berichtet darin über ein krankenhaus in
not es sind vor allem die mütter die an
den betten bangen baha ist mit ihren
beiden kindern hier sohn und tochter
leiden an den folgen schwerer
unterernährung
ich bin so müde von dieser situation wir
besitzen nichts meine kinder ich und
mein mann uns allen geht es sehr
schlecht
was danach passierte konnte die
reporterin nicht ahnen wir zeigen es
ihnen jetzt
diese fragt wird leben retten
25 tonnen medizinische hilfsgüter
schmerzmittel antibiotika und jede menge
hochkalorische babynahrung matthias
robben und cordula holding von der
hilfsorganisation arche war klar sie
müssen in afghanistan helfen
das schlimmste was ein kinderarzt
eigentlich passieren kann ist zu wissen
wie er helfen könnte es aber nicht zu
können weil medikamente fehlen oder
geräte nicht mehr funktionieren und das
heißt der beitrag hat mich persönlich
betroffen gemacht ich wollte nicht in
deren situation seien erfahrungen haben
sie bei arche mit vor allem in afrika es
ist die erste hilfslieferung die der
verein auf den weg nach afghanistan
bringt die fracht hat einen wert von
rund 25.000 euro was mit auf den weg
geht ist die ungewissheit ob die hilfe
dort ankommt wo sie hin soll
es bleibt ein restrisiko und das wird
sich erst auflösen wenn die sachen in
kabul bei dem dr gut ankommen das ist so
aber irgendwo muss man dann den schritt
machen und mutig sein und sagen wir
versuchen das jetzt einfach dass indira
gandhi kinderkrankenhaus in kabul die
fracht ist angekommen und sie wird
dringend gebraucht wie dringend zeigt
uns dr hat die kleine rosa ist zwei
monate alt sie hat eine infektion
eigentlich gar nichts schlimmes
wenn wir die richtigen medikamente
hätten würde sie überleben man kann sie
behandeln aber ohne und ohne die
richtigen geräte wird sich sterben
es fehlt an allem auf der neugeborenen
intensivstation sollte eine lampe den
säuglingen wärme spenden sie ist kaputt
und
die mütter viele haben kein geld für
medikamente sie haben nicht einmal geld
für essen und so wächst von tag zu tag
ein problem im land wie nah ist drei
jahre alt und wiegt 5,2 kilogramm nach
der behandlung mit spezialnahrung doch
davon ist einfach zu wenig da dr hachiko
muss entscheiden welches kind er ernährt
und welches nicht er entscheidet über
leben und tod
[Musik]
ich denke mittlerweile leiden mehr als
fünf millionen kinder in afghanistan an
unterernährung
ein gehalt hat dr hat google schon lange
nicht mehr bekommen auch seiner familie
droht der absturz in die armut doch
gerade jetzt wird er gebraucht denn es
wird ein harter winter in afghanistan
werden unterstützt wird er aus
deutschland auch in zukunft weitere
hilfslieferungen der organisation arche
mit sind schon in vorbereitung
ein beitrag von katrin eigendorf torge
bode und jörg christ und jetzt in der
sendung noch mal keine mit sportliche ja
zum beispiel musste die fußball
nationalmannschaft hat bei der wm
qualifikation um die es ja gar nicht
mehr gegen deutschland ist ja längst
qualifiziert spannend war eher die frage
wie bundestrainer flick in armenien
seinen ausgedünnten kader einsetzt und
sie gewinnen immer weiter vier zu
einzelner medien der siebte sieg im
siebten spiel unter hansi flick und das
obwohl neben den wegen quarantäne
fehlenden fünf autor edgar neuer und
reus nicht dabei sind harvards gegen
liechtensteiner zuschauer veredelt die
feine vorarbeit von hofmann und müller
zum 1 0 unmittelbar vor der pause foul
an neuer aus elf metern verwandelt
ebenso sicher wie schon gegen
liechtenstein
ilkay gündogan auch der schütze zum drei
zu null wobei armeniens toedter buch
nerv allzu hilfreich
assistiert
neuhaus vaterland rtl ii angibt armenien
die chance von eins zu drei
vegetarier an der einzige dortmunder
nutzt sie eventuelle zweifel beseitigt
jonas hofmann ebenso umgehend wie
überlegt vier zu eins für die deutsche
mannschaft die im märz da weitermachen
will wo sie für dieses jahr aufgehört
hat in der formel 1 ging es heute um den
großen preis von brasilien und gewonnen
hatten lewis hamilton nach einer
spektakulären aufholjagd denn gestartet
war der weltmeister von platz zehn bei
bull pilot max verstappen kam nach einem
kopf an kopf rennen als zweiter ins ziel
dritter wurde valtteri bottas im
mercedes in der wm-wertung liegt
hamilton jetzt noch 14 punkte hinter
fest an
mainz singt und lacht in diesen tagen
natürlich hat auch die gemütliche stadt
am rhein große corona sorgen und das
drückt die fasnacht stimmung aber der
oberbürgermeister sagt selbst der
haushalt habe ihm noch nie so viel spaß
gemacht wie jetzt das liegt daran dass
die hoch verschuldete stadt jetzt in
geld schwimmt der grund krone
beziehungsweise die rettung vor corona
der impfstoffhersteller biontech sitzt
in mainz und zahlt viel mehr
gewerbesteuer als alle anderen mainzer
unternehmen zusammen mainz nimmt deshalb
mehr als fünfmal so viel ein wie bisher
jetzt könnte man auf gedanken kommen wie
weiland sindelfingen das sich vom
daimler geld zebrastreifen aus marmor
gegönnt hatte aber mainz hat andere
ideen zeigt susanne gelhard
sie nennen es das wunder von mainz statt
36 millionen euro schulden in diesem
jahr ein haushaltsüberschuss von über
einer milliarde euro die gewerbesteuer
und bayon tag machen es möglich die
stadt hat jetzt grosse pläne
sie will ein globaler standort für
biotechnologie werden zum glück gibt es
einen großen leuchtturm das ist die
bekannte firma bayon tag aber wir haben
schon alle ein an rund ein dutzend
firmen die im umfeld von biotechnologie
am standort unterwegs sind die
landeshauptstadt mainz hat eine der
größten universitäten der republik seine
universitätsmedizin das ist eine gute
basis wie bei montech bewiesen hat
gleich neben dem hauptsitz wird mehr
raum für bayern tag und für mehr
wohnungen geschaffen auf insgesamt 30
hektar sollen sich in den nächsten zehn
jahren neue biotechnologie unternehmen
mit 5.000 arbeitsplätzen ansiedeln
zusätzlicher anreiz eine senkung der
gewerbesteuer um 30 prozent die stadt
mainz geht jetzt den richtigen weg mit
einer senkung einer gewerbesteuer und
kommt damit natürlich auch ein stück dem
unternehmen entgegen und ich glaube das
hat auch eine wirkung nach draußen und
macht meint damit natürlich auch ein
stück lukrativer für andere firmen für
andere ausgründung dass bayern tech
gründer parcours schein und smtp ist
meins eng verbunden seit über 20 jahren
forschen und lehren sie an der
universitätsmedizin mit finanzieller und
personeller förderung 2008 entstand bei
montech als ausgründung in 2021 stiegen
die nettogewinne rasant auf bisher über
7 milliarden euro
2022 könnte sich der absatz des corona
impfstoffs verdoppeln ich bin sicher
dass bei antec für viele ein mut
machendes beispiel ist nicht nur für
studierende die sich vielleicht
selbständig machen wollen sondern
vielleicht auch so hoffen wir jedenfalls
für risikokapitalgeber die sehen es
lohnt sich wirklich in so etwas zu
investieren
die studierenden der johannes
gutenberg-universität erwarten sich viel
vom geplanten biotechnologie standort
man hört immer wieder dass es keine
start up kultur gibt und so weiter von
daher ist glaube ich an den unis
anzusetzen eigentlich eine gute methode
und die eben zu fördern eigentlich
müsste man auch international komplett
bekannt sein weil der buchdrucker von
geworden ist halt einfach und wenn
natürlich jetzt so eine pionierin eine
weitere pionierleistung über 500 jahre
später mit dem impfstoff auch aus mainz
kommt ist grandios damals schrieb der
buchdrucker johannes gutenberg
geschichte jetzt verändert bei montech
die welt eine chance auch für mainz
absolut noch wirkt die lange zeit als
schulden statt nach es bröckelt noch in
mainz an vielen stellen aber die chance
jetzt ist historisch genau so wie die
gefahr sie zu versammeln wir werden vom
lerchenberg aus weiter genau hingucken
jetzt gucken wir in die woche die vor
uns liegt der heute journal ausblick von
jörg will
[Musik]
die dramatische lage an der polnisch
bella russischen grenze wird morgen auch
thema in brüssel sein dann werden die
eu-außenminister über eine weitere
verschärfung der sanktionen gegen
belarus beraten im fokus
fluggesellschaften die bei der
schleusung von flüchtlingen helfen
was hat die arbeitswelt durch corona
gelernt oder auch nicht welche
politischen schwerpunkte müssen künftig
gesetzt werden fragen denen sich unions
spitzen und pampel koalitionäre am
dienstag stellen werden beim deutschen
arbeitgebertag in berlin
am donnerstag will der bundestag das
neue
infektionsschutzgesetz beschließen spd
grüne und fdp hatten die änderungen
vorgeschlagen in kürze läuft die
epidemische lage aus und damit die
rechtsgrundlage vieler corona maßnahmen
das erzbistum köln wird am donnerstag
einem bußgottesdienst für die opfer
sexuellen missbrauchs durch die
katholische kirche abhalten man solle um
vergebung für die fehler des erzbistums
bitten wo die schuld gegenüber den
betroffenen bekennen
und noch ein ausblick hier ist das
wetter für die meisten wird der
wochenstart trübe aber trocken sonnig
wird es nur in ostbayern an den nordwest
rändern einiger mittelgebirge und auf
vielen bergen 6 bis 13 grad auch in den
folgenden tagen ist die sonne nur selten
zu sehen ab mittwoch regnet es im norden
und der wind wird stärker das ganze bei
maximal 4 bis 2 grad
ja und mit diesen mitteln erfreulichen
aussichten sagen wir danke für ihr
interesse an diesem sonntag und morgen
freuen sich dank modul ag und claus
kleber auf sie von uns zwei für heute an
sie einen angenehm haben
[Musik]